because we are talking about war there
is still tragedy and loss and darkness
there and that's okay
and do you vets out there
if you're having one of those dark days
it's okay
it's it's okay
it's okay to feel that darkness
and it's okay to remember it and miss it
then Hagen
and love it
and it's okay to wish it never happened
and at the same time to wish it never
stopped and it's okay to want to take it
all back
and at the same time
to want to do it all again
in it and if you've got in your mind
that that that you think that people
don't understand
that's okay
they don't what you do
you know darkness you know evil
but for it
it back
you know good
light you know laughter and love better
than anyone
so
embrace
embrace that darkness own it the look
away from it don't bury it in booze or
pills live your life
embrace your life
with with physical activity with nature
and with jiu-jitsu and with Sun and with
laughter and guitar and good memories
and creativity and discipline
discipline yourself
so you can freeze
phone
into the future
where there's no more darkness no more
but peace
you